benvenuti in un luogo format da me
inventato chiamato crisi di mezza età
con gli eau topi anzi depressione con
gli atomici molto accattivante
stiamo tornando dalla valtellina questo
è il viaggio di ritorno di un'esperienza
che abbiamo voluto fare io ho voluto
fare poi lui purtroppo dovuto venire per
forza per girare vi ricordate quando ho
detto che mi sarebbe piaciuto essere
come ellen e fare come melaverde c'è un
programma blando né bello né brutto che
nessuno avrebbe potuto mai criticare
eccoci il perché di questo viaggio di
questo contenuto è presto detto domenica
scorso compiuto 31 anni sono
letteralmente troppo vecchio per questa
piattaforma che potrebbe essere il nome
di un titolo me e io non so quanto
durerà o ancora e quindi mi voglio
togliere ogni sfizio voglio fare anche
qualcosa che piace a me non che piace a
me ma che c'è chi se ne frega se non va
bene sembra male non importa ed
esattamente come la verde l lo faccio
per te perché sarebbe dovuto essere un
formato leggere un po scanzonato per
l'estate
e invece si trasforma sempre come come
me lo immagino io si trasforma sempre in
una seduta psicoanalitica della vita e
del futuro incerto
tutti noi siamo partiti per fare questo
viaggio da milano più precisamente dal
ristorante sciatta portello giusto
esatto c'è un ristorante tipico
valtellinese dove abbiamo assaggiato i
pizzoccheri e tutto il resto e del meno
onesto perché la proprietaria del
ristorante si è presa bene il fatto che
stessimo facendo un video e ci ha fatto
assaggiare qualsiasi cosa e infatti la
inquadratura sicuramente quella lì
prenderà in pieno gli home panzer quindi
reticenti abbiamo mangiato nell'ordine
gli sciatt i pizzoccheri un piattone di
pizzoccheri la bresaola normale la
bresaola di cervo tarozzo età ros non
uno non due non quattro ma tre dolci e
dopo esserci presi tre o quattro maalox
siamo partiti siamo partiti alla volta
di sondrio che sono circa due ore
auto 630 chilometri sotto il diluvio
universale stava piovendo come la merda
si è vero la prima cosa che abbiamo
fatto è stata sbagliare strada ci siamo
persi proveremo ci sono tre strade
abbiamo preso uno siamo finiti in una
cava
quindi voglio dire siamo vicini il direi
guardiamo su google maps non ti prendi
te ringraziamo decathlon per i keeway
che abbiamo comprato poco prima che ci
hanno un po salvato la vita devo dire e
hanno trasformato tutte quante le
fotografie in della locandina di it
siamo arrivati nella località dove
dovevamo arrivare che acquanegra un
chiodo un botto è però ce l'abbiamo
fatta e adesso dobbiamo farci quarantina
di minuti a piedi da questa strada 4 il
lieve scritto una rendita eva peron
respiro aria verrà a differenza di
torino che ricordiamo è al numero uno
della posizione delle polveri sottili in
italia li abbiamo fermato la macchina
abbiamo pranzato al buonissimo e ci
siamo incamminati
controlli a trovare è e che mi piace per
fortuna però del figlio dei proprietari
dell'alpeggio è venuto a prenderci la
roma sono per prenderci l'attrezzature
gli zaini le valigie in modo da farci
salire con più calma a piedi grazie per
questo
[Musica]
stiamo riprendendo fiato
possiamo dirlo siamo cittadini il
contrario di pozzetto questi ragazzi in
città
certo qualche errore c'è stato
[Musica]
una delle cose che ti dicono per fare
tipo trekking o camminata è quella di
comprarti delle scarpe da camminare e
l'ho fatto ho preso le più scarse da
poter distruggere la decathlon a 990 al
paio e le ho dimenticate nella valigia e
sto facendo il video con le clarks
perdonatemi sbagliano tutte le i tempi
verbali perché fra racconta quello che è
successo siamo ancora freschi del dramma
paesaggi splendidi la pioggia che
ringraziando il signore ha fatto
scappare tutti gli effetti non c'era
neanche una farfallina io ti ringrazio
dio dei tempi delle vespe grazie 8 gradi
questo è il paradiso
ne ho fatta l'abbiamo fatta poi non
avevamo più un culo sani che ti sani e
arriviamo allo spiazzo più bello che io
abbia mai visto
certo c'è da dire che era 15 anni che
non andavo in montagna quindi qualsiasi
cosa gli sarebbe stata bellissima
però quello spiazzo in particolare stare
breve senza fiato ci ha lasciati siamo
arrivati
[Musica]
siamo arrivati all'alpeggio aquanera
dell'azienda agricola agneta che ci ha
felicemente devo dire o ospitati per la
notte
se abbiamo stato a tutti gli effetti
adottati dal loro presidente
sì ci hanno adottato per una giornata
intera ho subito fatto la figura del
milanese che vai in vacanza perché mi
hanno visto adesso delle scarpe ci hanno
offerto vino immediatamente vino
formaggi formaggi un risotto incredibile
e poi siccome si era fatta una certa per
essere un'azienda agricola erano circa
le dieci e mezza
siamo immediatamente andati a dormire
[Musica]
volevo spiegarvi un attimo il perché di
questo viaggio quello che ho detto
all'inizio del video è vero nel senso ha
31 anni inizio a sentirmi un pochino
fuori posto nella piattaforma non tanto
a livello di contenuti quanto proprio
d'età e quindi scatta immediatamente il
periodo cosa sto facendo della mia vita
perché sono ancora qui perché hai
accettato di venire con me a fare questa
follia e questo l'ho notato anche solo
dal cambio di contenuti che adesso io
apprezzo di più su youtube e alcuni
contenuti che magari prima mi sembravano
un po troppo leggeri o un po troppo
diciamo quasi televisivi adesso li
apprezzo molto di più
blogger per esempio come nick d'avella
all nostrano marcello ascani ho iniziato
a a guardarli in modo con occhio più
approfondito ma anche canali
l'intrattenimento base come marco robert
che l'ingegnere della nasa è entrata in
di elk poiché safia che è diventata una
delle mie creators preferite ma
soprattutto mi ha colpito molto
living big in time i auser che è questo
format veramente sembra uscito da sky di
questo ragazzo che va e viene invitato
nelle case più piccole del mondo e ce ne
fa vedere ce lo permette ai proprietari
di mostrarcele non lo so mi affascina
molto mi piacerebbe tantissimo fare dei
contenuti del genere in futuro dunque li
all'alpeggio sveglia alle 5 per andare a
mungere le mucche e adesso andremo a
raccogliere adesso quindi non a
raccogliere e fortunatamente erano
addestrate e incredibile ma stavo a
chiamarle così e non arrivavano in fila
indiana per andare verso la il capanno
dove poi giungerle è la prima cosa che
ho chiesto è stato posto accarezzarle
hanno detto sì e localizzate tutte
quanto non mi ha lasciata 1
[Musica]
alla fine sono molto abituato hanno
fatto tutto del sole poi ogni tanto
qualcuna stava deviando non so se hai
ripreso io facevo proprio da vigile loro
si spostavano l'incredibile è stato
bellissimo
ovviamente alessio era preso benissimo
quando hanno detto sì si giungerà le
vacche lui già si stava sfregando le
mani detto no era una delle immagini che
proprio volevo vedere tra figura di meno
invece no invece no perché le vacche non
si mungono non li pongono almeno lì e
all'alpeggio a mano ma di pungolo con un
macchinario non git reach e
[Musica]
adragna e sono stato bravissimo perché è
entrato mi hanno dato questo seggiolino
che è un pezzettino di legno con un
gambo senza senza un appoggio vero e
proprio per terra e lui è il segno già
per farlo ingaggio mi avete già se
riesci a sederti un gran passo mi sono
seduto subito sei il nostro orgoglio
ne abbiamo molti più di 90 litri 10
vacca incredibili avevano due cani
stupendi stupendi
[Musica]
poi dopo aver molto le vacche è arrivata
la colazione perché prima solo caffè
particolarità del nel posto in meno 30
gradi di temperatura e c'era solo questa
camicia a quadri sono freddo vecchia
[Musica]
e dopo la frazione abbiamo avuto
l'opportunità di far due domande con il
figlio dei proprietari e anche lui ha 31
anni quindi è stato un po come vedere al
di là dello specchio 1 team c'è qualcosa
che invece magari tu avresti voluto fare
o magari ti piacerebbe fare comunque 31
anni né che siano
ecco l'unico pallino che mai rimasto che
mi piacerebbe fare è che non riesco a
fare che non ho mai fatto e non dico di
andare in vacanza però a me questo
lavoro mi piace tanto mi piacerebbe per
dire andare dall'altra parte del mondo
va in america ma in italia a vedere come
lavorano cioè le differenze che ci sono
cioè per dire a quella sarebbe la
vacanza perché mi piacerebbe dire di
recapito vedere altre realtà perché alla
fine me piace andare perché c'è più che
a lavorare quasi una scelta di vita
la pena stavamo iniziando ad abituarci
al terreno agli animali al al campo
minato che era in quel prato lì perché
ogni due passi c'era un'enorme
defecazione di mucca ma proprio e non
delle mine antiuomo gigantesche è un
certo punto siamo scesi portando il
latte che è stato molto per fare per
andare a fare in formaggi decidono di
non farci andare per pietà decidono di
non farci andare a premi giù come
l'andata
ma andiamo con il loro quad elettrico e
io ho detto cazzo fighissimo il cuore
elettrico
però voi state dietro
venivamo sballottati come i barili della
arrivati jun sani e salvi più salvi che
sabatini secondo me
arriviamo in questa casetta diciamo
mezzo caseificio dove loro fanno il
formaggio e lì ci hanno mostrato tutti i
passaggi che alessio essendo perito
agrario l'unico lavoro nella mia vita
che è c'entrava con quella col mio
percorso di studi volti parlarono tutti
con lui perché era lui che firmava tutto
io stavo in piedi con le braccia
conserte ad aspettare in che facessero
tutti i passaggi
[Musica]
loro scaldano il latte ne giungono il
taglio mettono il caglio dentro che è un
estratto dall intestino della mucca me
pare aspetti che il caglio faccio a
coagulare le proteine del latte
ok e vengono a galla e si forma una
specie di budino loro lo tagliano questo
mourinho con questo attrezzo
[Musica]
talmente tanto che poi diventa quasi
riso sembra la grandezza dei chicchi di
riso e poi cosa fanno
lo estraggono umano lo scalda scaldano
ancora dicembre per italiani ho
sbagliato dieci anni va a un certo punto
la cagliata che sono questi chicchi e
vengono raggruppati e vengono tolte
messi nelle forme che vengono pressate
per far uscire tutto il il siero e lo
immettere un peso sopra per per dargli
la forma in freddo che poi quel liquido
lì viene usato per fare la ricotta
esatto insieme di tool aggiungi l'acido
citrico e e si forma anche lì una nuova
coagulazione che è la ricotta e la
ricotta e la mettono nelle piccole
fornire il professor si stanno
rivoltando to fail videomaker avessero
intenzionale ci sarà un motivo
un altro ci ha spiegato il proprietario
che tutta la roba al cento per cento che
usano loro è di loro proprietà a partire
dal latte fino ad arrivare alla legna
che viene usata per scaldarlo il latte
già anche fatto vedere la
la cantina la sua cantina dove ci sono
le forme che stato sta giocando fatte da
loro un odore era talmente forte l'odore
della cantina che non sapeva neanche di
muffa sai della crosta dei formaggi ma
sapeva di pesce
non so perché ha fatto tutto il giro
l'odore è diventato fortissimo e acceso
e quindi la mattinata l'abbiamo fatta
siamo partiti dal prendere il latte fino
a trasformarlo in ricotto in formaggio e
adesso dobbiamo andare via da questo
splendido paesaggio le due cose che mi
hanno spinto di più per fare questo
viaggio qui a parte il fatto del non
essere mai stato
quando tu fai le cose a polsi impulsivo
non sono mai stato nella mia vita mi
faccio sempre un sacco di pipponi
mentali ogni volta che devo fare
qualcosa e una anzi due delle cose che
mi hanno spinto a farlo sono stati
conoscere non di persona purtroppo ma ti
ammiraglio e il ragazzo che purtroppo mi
ricordo come si chiama adesso di trip
terapie ma ti ammiraglio e questo
ragazzo che ha fatto il giro per il
mondo a piedi
soluri a un certo punto ha detto cioè
cosa non ho voglia di andare al
carrefour a prendermi il solito estate 0
e bear melo in camminando per torino ma
voglio voglio andare a fare un giro del
mondo e ha preso in pochissimo tempo da
quando l'ha pensato e partito così
all'improvviso
certo poi si è sfasciato le ginocchia
metà mia però l'ha fatto ed è una cosa
che io non sono proprio livello di
persona e questo mi ha bloccato dal fare
un sacco di cose
l'altra è stato come dicevo prima
ragazzo di trip therapy anche lui un
sacco di centinaia forse migliaia di
chilometri a piedi completamente in
silenzio senza ascoltare musiche senza
parlare con nessuno e lui ha detto una
frase la potete sentire nell'intervista
di montemagno dove dice che riusciva a
sentire la pausa tra un pensiero e
l'altro io l'ho ascoltato del tu
io non mi ricordo di aver mai smesso di
pensare da quando sono nato e mi
dispiace mi dispiace davvero non avere
usato la mia
chiamiamola tra virgolette fa male nei
numeri per viaggiare anche gratis ed è
molto molto semplice perché appena
abbiamo voluto fare questa cosa qui a
parte i ristoranti e le location che ci
hanno ospitato in modo assolutamente
contentissimo dei soci ha detto o se
volete vi possiamo dare la macchina per
il viaggio e ci hanno dato la macchina
quelli viaggio che lo fece cazzo è così
facile adesso chiedo qualsiasi cosa che
tra l'altro è da ringraziare preso
perché mi sa che senza questa macchina
sarebbe stato un problema di girare per
sobrio e tra l'altro è molto meglio
infatti appena siamo tornati
dall'alpeggio verso l'hotel abbiamo
detto non siamo stanchi per niente
perché non andiamo a visitare un
castello e siamo andati a visitare
questo castello c'era la parte sopra dei
vigneti incredibili altro rischiando più
e più volte di morire male male c'è
scritto nigri però poi siamo arrivati e
vi ricordate quando ho detto che la
pioggia ha allontanato gli effetti il
giorno prima e poi arriva l'ora di
andare al ristorante tripi propriano i
ristoranti signor gianluca già ospitato
per fare i pizzoccheri spalle ricetta di
sciopero prevede l'utilizzo di queste
due famiglie o su un chilo di farina di
farace lo metto 300 grammi
[Musica]
penso di aver fatto da altri ingredienti
che sono le verdure le patate
io qui ti ho preparato un misto tra una
verso la nostra e il cavolo nero pete
letto che portassero alla mia età gli
altri ingredienti fondamentali per
finire il piatto solo il formaggio si a
parte si fa quella che viene chiamata
volgarmente la sferzata 1
[Musica]
e con bicchiere di vino abbiamo siglato
il piatto buonissimo era buonissimo
non mi sarei mai aspettato vero e
proprio buono è quello è stato alla fine
del nostro viaggio il nuovo fatto per
per me diciamo per il futuro per vedere
se sarei riuscito a creare magari un
format da zero un format che si fa da sé
e che mi faccia fare cose completamente
diverse dal progetto youth ovi perché
credo manchi poco ormai alla fine del
progetto yotobi mandare curriculum
succede io tommy credo ha mai abbia dato
quello che c'era da dare e in futuro
farò alto sempre su youtube ma magari su
altri canali con altri nomi e lo dici
così nella bottega si è mai lasciato su
una tristezza questa finale toppo e sono
proprio tutte queste cose qua c'è una
scampagnata no è il mio testamento
virtuale contenuti quando mangia di
pizzoccheri che abbiamo mangiato pizza
che per un anno a vederla
[Musica]